Wright's breakfast is one of the most
important meal of the day so I'm putting
the challenge out there to see if
breakfast can be made in ten minutes and
I think I know just the person to
perfect it Mia can you make the
delicious breakfast in ten
welcome to Ramsey in ten
I am Mia Castro and you may remember me
from Hell's Kitchen I'm in Chef Ramsay's
Kitchen today he's challenged me to make
breakfast and today I'm making my recipe
for pumpkin spice pancakes with this
recipe I'm showing you why there's no
excuse why you can't make breakfast in
10 minutes or less I ready to get
started let's put the time on the clock
right here I just have my dry
ingredients they're actually gluten free
so we have some almond flour and we're
doing about a half a cup then we have
some arrowroot starch for lightness we
have some baking powder a couple
teaspoons and some salt add a teaspoon
let's get all together we just want to
incorporate all of that so it's even set
aside for a second that were combining
all of our wet ingredients I just
eyeball it it's about a cup of pumpkin
puree and you should have this on hand
from your Thanksgiving meal we probably
have some leftovers so that should be
easy
three eggs so then we're doing a
teaspoon of vanilla combine all of this
really well adding some chai spice mix
into our dry spices and I just make a
premade mix at home and it's a
combination of ginger cardamom cinnamon
cloves allspice little nutmeg I like to
make them ahead of time and just have it
on hand for other dishes you can put it
in french toast or put it over your
coffee and then we mix in the wet and
the dry I'm just gonna transfer some of
this batter into a measuring cup so it's
easy to pour
so I have a griddle pan right here I'm
just gonna spray it with some coconut
oil and if you don't have one that's
fine you can just use a nonstick pan at
home I'm gonna do about a quarter cup
for pancake
and we're gonna cook them until they're
just set on the sides and they're
starting to bubble in the center then
while these cook I'm going to make a
quick sauce for them to make them a
little harder what I have here is a
little bit of melted coconut oil and so
we just want to get our coconut oil nice
and warm to melt this almond butter that
I'm about to put in I'm gonna do about
half a cup of almond butter maybe like
don't forget your pancakes we're gonna
burn them then when they start bubbling
in the middle like this means they're
ready and then I like to spray them on
top
[Applause]
I don't have to look perfect it's just
breakfast and you're home but they're
gonna be delicious so while those cook
I'm gonna finish my almond butter sauce
and the reason why I do this is so I'm
not dousing them that much with maple
syrup and I'm avoiding a little bit of
that sugar and we're going with a little
bit of this maple syrup to sweeten it
just a bit and some of the chive spices
to keep going with that theme a little
vanilla and a little bit of salt and
everything that's sweet
and you want to turn the heat off you
don't want it to get too hot because the
almond butter will melt just needs a
little bit of sweetness and these
pancakes are ready so we're ready to
serve what's the time right now
so finish it with this almond butter
sauce it's nice and sweet and salty some
more chai spices and that's it so
another challenge I proved Gordon right
pumpkin pancakes in ten minutes
thank you so much for joining me let me
know what you think in the comments
below don't forget to subscribe to
Gordon's YouTube channel for more Ramsay
intent